the Republican front runner for
president wants to bring Trump
University to all Americans for free I'm
announcing today we will take the
billions and billions of dollars that we
will collect by taxing fining and suing
excessively large private university
endowments and we will then use that
money to endow a new institution called
the American Academy its Mission will be
to make a truly worldclass education
available to every American free of
charge and do it without adding a single
dime to the federal debt the libs are
going to lose their minds as will the
Libertarians as will the Republican
establishment as will many fancy
conservative movement types who went to
brandname schools and fill their
mahogany home libraries with many Dusty
books and
yet this is a great idea